joining us now is Victor Davis Hanson
senior fellow at the Hoover institution
uh Victor you live in the Central Valley
of California kind of the Bread Basket
of the United States but they want to
shut down debate here and say it's just
the right Wingers who are I guess trying
to protect the farmers and in the
Netherlands like what what is this
really about Victor
it's pretty pathetic it's a it's a
pathetic use of government control by a
small Elite you know when they can't
address the existential problem that
China and India are polluting
contributing to 40 percent of greenhouse
gas releases or their Elites are
contributing to it with private jet
travel they go under the misdemeanors
and they pick on 17
000 Dutch Farmers I mean my God these
people are the most efficient Dairy
Farmers in the world they've got a
global reputation for land stewardship
we were told all during the 90s Laura
that we've got to go back to organic
natural farming too much chemical
nitrates and the dairy became the Nexus
where everybody looks toward organic
manures to be supplied by dairies and
then we were told of course we have to
innovate if you're on the farm family
Farmers have to get with it if you look
at a pound of meat or milk produced
versus the unit of methane gas released
the Dutch are the most efficient farmers
in the world everyone buddy should be
looking at Dutch farming especially
Dairy farming for a model of how to be
sustainable and how to promote democracy
by keeping Farmers on the land
generation after generation and officers
it just doesn't make sense yeah sorry
Victor
absolutely yeah and that's because if
you don't control your own food supply
as a people you you you are deeply
vulnerable to exploitation and coercion
from government authorities
um
American and European farmers are the
best in the world they're the most
they're the best stewards or the most
efficient and they it would be
absolutely insane to go after them it's
sort of the equivalent of the military
going after rural kids that to provide
the best fighters in the world I don't
know why we do this but it's we've got
to stop it these are our strengths these
are our assets farmers in Europe and the
United States and we should they're
sacrosanct and to go after them is a
crime Victor thank you so much great to
see you tonight hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else